- [Instructor] Talk a little bit about
biogeochemical cycles.
And the term biogeochemical
sounds very fancy.
But really these are
just cycles that involve
different molecules that
are essential for life
and how they circulate
through and an ecosystem
and really how they
circulate through the entire,
through an entire biosphere.
And the molecules that we care about,
and molecules that could
consist of one element
or multiple elements.
They are things like
well, water molecules.
H2O.
Oxygen and hydrogen
make up a lot of living,
a lot of living creatures,
a lot of biomass.
And water is just an essential element
that is involved in life as we know it.
We're also gonna be talking about carbon.
And carbon takes on may forms
when we think about biogeochemical cycles.
There's carbon dioxide in the air.
There's a lot of carbon
in organic molecules
that form up most of the
mass of life as we know it.
And there is actors that maybe
don't get as much attention.
There are things like nitrogen
and of course, you have characters like,
characters like phosphorus.
And you might say, "Okay, I
get that most organic molecules
"are made up of a bunch
of carbons and hydrogens
"and every now and then, oxygens.
"But what about nitrogens?
"And what about phosphorus?"
And remember, your DNA,
deoxyribonucleic acid.
We're talking about nitrogenous bases.
Your adenines and guanines
and all these things
that we talk about in DNA,
they involve nitrogen.
And there's other biomolecules.
Amino acids, proteins, amino
acids which make up proteins
that involve nitrogen.
Phosphorus, ATP.
The adenosine triphosphate.
It's essential.
It's in that core biomolecule.
It's also in the backbone of DNA.
So these are all essential
elements for life.
And the key thing is,
is that they all get recycled
through biogeochemical cycles.
So they are all recycled.
We talked about how an
ecosystem energy flows.
It might start with
light energy from the sun
and then over time as it's
transferred form one form
to another as it flows
from one form to another,
it gets dissipated as heat.
But the matter, the
elements, the molecules here.
This is recycled.
It was a originally formed.
I mean there's a few meteorites
that hit every now and then.
But the most part,
most of the matter around
us was here at the dawn of,
when the earth was first formed.
It was first created in the
inside due to fusion reactions
of stars billions and billions
and billions of years ago.
So all of life, everything
that we've seen so far
in the history of earth,
for the most part,
it's the same elements
and the same molecules
that have been recycled over
and over and over again.
And so when we think about
biogeochemical cycles,
we will think about things like,
if we're talking about H20,
we're gonna think about the water cycle.
Water cycle.
And we have a whole video on that
but in (stutters) the short version of it
is you could have water actually stored
in a multiple different ways.
Some of it couldn't evaporate
as water vapor.
Eventually it condenses
in the form of clouds
and then it can rain back down
and along the way, you could have animals
that get access especially
to the fresh water
and make that part of the
actual living organisms.
You actually, I also have living organisms
that view the water as
part of their ecosystem
but we go into some
depth in another video.
You'll also hear people talk about,
if we're talking about carbon,
the carbon cycle.
The carbon cycle.
And just as a very high level of overview
of the carbon cycle.
So let's say that's the ground.
Let's say that this is
a plant right over here.
Take primary producer and autotroph.
We talk about that in our ecosystem video.
So let me draw a leaf here.
This is a plant that is growing.
What it's doing while
it takes light energy,
so it gets light energy from the sun.
So that's the light
energy right over there
and it uses that light
energy to fix carbon.
The carbon that is making up this plant.
It's just not emerging out of nowhere,
it's being recycled.
It's being recycled from carbon molecules
that are in the air.
So the carbon molecules in the air,
they're going to be, or
the carbon in the air,
it's gonna be in molecular form in terms
it's going to be carbon dioxide.
So that over there is CO2.
And so the plant uses that light energy
and that gaseous, that CO2 gas,
and it's able to fix the
carbon to construct it.
So it's looks like that
plant is just growing.
It's not clear where all
that mass is coming from.
But it literally is coming from the air.
And it might be able to get,
it might get a few of the nutrients.
Especially things like nitrogen phosphorus
from the ground and that's
where we could go into the whole
nitrogen and phosphorus cycles.
But then once these plants
fix all of this carbon,
some of it gets stored in the biomass,
sometimes the plant dies
and then it gets buried
and if there was enough pressure,
it can turn into a hydrocarbons.
So a hydrocarbons, when you
fuel your car, it's a really
it's really energy stored by dead plants
a long long time ago that got
buried and put into that form
but it was essentially
plants through photosynthesis
that first stored that energy.
But then of course, and
we've talked about this,
you can have animals
that eat those plants.
So let me draw an animal
that is eating it.
So that looks like an animal.
Well that one looks like something
that likes to eat more than just plants.
So this is, you draw it like
it's like an alligator
chicken looking thing.
Well, that's close enough.
Well you get the idea.
When it eats that plant, it's
using some of that carbon
that was fixed originally by
that plant for it's own biomass
but it'll also as it metabolizes
the some of it (stutters)
it will use that the bond,
the energy stored in those chemical bonds,
to live and grow and move about.
And as it does that,
it will exhale the CO2.
So that the CO2 goes back
into the environment.
Now this is a huge oversimplification
of the carbon cycle
but this is the general idea.
And eventually this thing might die
or might get eaten by other consumers.
And then you have the
decomposers down here
who could further make use
of those chemical bonds
that the primary producer first created
using that light energy.
Decom, decomposers right over here.
And they might also, as they consume that,
release more CO2 which will
eventually then get fixed again
by a primary producer.
And there's similar cycles
for nitrogen and phosphorus.
These often involving bacteria
to fix the nitrogen and
the phosphorus from the air
to make it available as
nutrients in the soil
for some of the primary producers in say,
the carbon cycle.
And nitrogen doesn't
get a lot of attention,
but this is actually the
most gas in our atmosphere.
So it's all around you right now
even while we're breathing,
we are breathing a lot of nitrogen.
Although it doesn't play as
strong of a role as say oxygen
and the oxygen in the air is
going to be molecular oxygen.
So I could also write O2 right over here.
Or as we breathe out,
carbon dioxide.
So I could write C
CO2.
CO2 right over there.
But hopefully this gives you a sense
of how matter is recycled.
Energy is flowing through ecosystems
including the largest ecosystems on earth
which is earth is biosphere.
You have matter being constantly recycled.
And the cycle of that matter,
we call biogeochemical cycles.
I think I just said the word cycle a lot.